so Andrew Tate who has also been on the
show decided to weigh in on this topic
there's a guy called adam22 once again I
have no idea who this man I just saw on
Twitter yesterday that he was with a
porn star who'd never done a male scene
they got married and like a week after
their marriage she did her first male
scene with some random dude and he's on
a podcast defending it why this is the
level you could this but this is what
the Matrix wants from you as a man they
want the woman in charge and the man
below with no backbone because if the
woman's in charge they can emotionally
affect her they can scare her it takes
real stoicism to lead so why are these
women unhappy because no one's leading
them no fathers no man of no backbone no
man they respect so they're relying on
society which is promoting chaos and
their own mental state Adam 22 comments
and he says if he's the top G I can be
the bottom this is a this isn't a good
look I don't even know how you'll ever
be respected by a guy again or really
women to be honest